good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday hey
claude how are you doing it's not only
monday it is happy last monday before
jackie goes on her maternity leave so i
think the better question is jackie how
are you doing thank you for asking i
know as i said it i was going to say
like this is my last happy monday for a
while but i just feel like that's too
sad for everyone i didn't want to remind
everyone but it's true this is my last
monday on the show for a while and i'm
doing good i mean
i'm more out of breath than ever so just
bear with bear with me did you listen to
my story the other day when i was
talking about how i get so out of breath
on podcasts because i watch your stories
with sound because i respect you thank
you so much well you've been doing
closed captioning because you respect me
and i appreciate that yes but if you
listen to the most recent episode of the
redheads where i really like host and i
talk a lot yeah at one point it sounds
like i'm about to break down and start
crying like
everyone else was just like waiting for
me to stop and we all started laughing
so hard i was so out of breath and they
were like how does that not happen to
you on the toast and i was like claudia
never lets me speak for this long and
that's why like what i do is so
important you know
i didn't even realize how much oxygen
you're saving me by cutting the office
see that's the thing like i care so much
about the health and wellness of you and
your child that i won't let you speak
because i know it's not good for you you
know
yeah no you're such a giver thank you so
much you know what not to cut you off
i actually like people always say like
claudia never lets jackie talk yeah i
know and if it was something i could
control like i swear to god i would stop
it's no disrespect to you at all but i
did listen to another pot i won't say
what it was i listened to another
podcast this weekend with two hosts and
my god one of them did not shut the [ __ ]
up and i was like let this other person
get a word in and i'm like oh my god is
this how people feel listening to our
show
i wonder and i'm so curious to know what
podcast you listen to i'll tell you
after just the one that was talking like
is like just kind of annoying and like
that's literally me like i am really
concerned now that i'm giving off the
same energy and to everyone who's ever
had to listen to an episode of this
podcast like i do apologize but you know
what i realized okay two things i'm
gonna say one first i listened to
another podcast a while ago and one
person was cutting off the other person
i was like what was the other person
gonna say can you shut up
but sometimes you cut me off when like i
wasn't gonna say anything much more
impactful
so you're kind of like saving me and
making it look like you're leaving them
wanting more
but i had nothing to say no if anything
like i'm the villain of this podcast and
i'm only helping your like q ratings go
up
thank you so much
that's what i that's why i do what i do
honestly you're such a giver we so
appreciate it um
i want to hear how your weekend was at
the farm we're so glad to see you back
home that you decided that you would go
back home
i know it you know what like
it did because if it wasn't like a
sunday there would have been nothing
telling me to come back home but we do
have a really busy week this week and i
and i'm also going back out on tour this
weekend so i just wanted to um
like reset at home even though i do miss
the farm life but i did have such a
great weekend i went out in philly
because brian really lives like equally
between philly and new york city so we
decided to go out in philly and i had so
much fun like philly is lit i went all
over we went to this place
fabrica which is like dinner theater
so you eat the food was actually
poisonous but like it didn't matter
because they put on such a great show
they had like aerial dancers drag queens
um comedians like it was just like a
really cool concept for
for a restaurant like there's i don't
think there's anything like that in new
york there was burlesque it was very
very cool we had a lot of fun that's
really cool i feel like there's a lot of
that in like um
where did i see it where was i like in
um
in europe like in san tropez like that's
what they do like those dinner shows
um and they're really amazing and i feel
like no one's been able to do like a
good job of replicating it here
necessarily but it sounds like that's
exactly what you experienced
and like the restaurant was beautiful we
sat down it was like it feels like ibiza
it was really exciting it would be
ibiza i think that's really
really cool
yeah right yeah so um that was really
fun and then we hit up a bunch of gay
bars which are just different than the
gay bars in new york like they were just
so complex and so different and they
were like multi-leveled so the one that
we ended up at tavern on camach i think
i'm pronouncing that correctly um the
first floor is like a piano bar which
you know i love i did perform a song
because it was like karaoke and i like
no one was living for it like they're
like get this girl out of here um yeah
so sad and i have the whole thing on
video and like i refuse to watch it or
send it to anyone because i really
thought i did something but i was like
blacked out and i was drinking fireball
and tequila which i never do like i
always stick with tequila so i was just
out of control um
and my voice was just like not where it
needed to be so that video will never
see the light of day and there were a
few toasters there so if you guys heard
that no you didn't okay okay you know
what that's actually the perfect story
um just to segue quickly into our first
edition of unburning yourselves today
and i feel like that's actually a really
embarrassing um little anecdote that you
just shared and i appreciate you
unburdening yeah i'm unburdening myself
in the spirit of the segment
yes today is our first day we've
collected we got so many emails you guys
everyone unburdening themselves with
embarrassing [ __ ] that they've done over
the weekend so we'll be sharing that at
the end of the show and thank you to
everyone who submitted don't worry it is
of course anonymous and if you want to
submit it's not too late unburden
yourselves at gmail.com
great so then we went to the thing about
philly is that like in city proper there
are casinos so it was like really cool
to go from like bar to bar to casino
like we don't have that sort of
lifestyle in new york and we spent like
the next four or five hours at the
casino just being like blacked out and
diabolical then we went to wawa and then
we fell asleep in the car ride home and
it was it was really a gorgeous night
like really one of my best nights for
real did you win money or did you lose
money
what do you think i guess you would have
said we went to the casino and i won
money if you had won no
but the thing is were the losses
were the losses staggering
no so for me when i go to a casino it's
not about winning it's about losing the
least amount possible and i've
definitely lost way more than i did on
saturday friday night so i feel good
about it
okay okay it could be worse and you had
a good time and
sometimes that's the price you pay
exactly
um how was your weekend i'm sure similar
vibes similar vibes went to the casino
brew and i went to a gay bar where brew
staying at the piano but he was a hit
that was the difference everyone was
living for it of course um no i i had a
productive weekend in the sense that i
watched relevant television you guys
not just poldark which i finished and
i'm so glad that it's over and that
there's not a new season coming thank
you goodbye good day sir thank you
thank you next and then i treated myself
finally to real housewives of miami and
it was such a treat oh my god i'm so
excited to talk about it like here's the
thing i miss i mean first of all the
show is amazing and it's on another
level than the other shows than the
crapola that we're watching
but two like i really miss like binge
watching housewives is what like why
life is about wives it's what life is
about if i was watching these episodes
week to week i i don't know that i would
say that they're so amazing because it's
not like so much happened but i was just
able to like really enter the world and
it wasn't like so
every week i'm into it and then it's
over so it was really enjoyable to binge
watch it obviously that doesn't work for
the other shows because we recap them
here but it kind of like reignited my
love for housewives which i know all of
you know has been lacking and it just
gives like og vibes like rich amazing
editing it looks like selling sunset
like it's gorgeous it's really gorgeous
and i can't wait to recap it i'm so
excited to recap it i'm so glad that you
watched too because we'll both share our
thoughts even though we were like
facetiming all weekend about it laughing
so [ __ ] hard um
and then i thought i watched something
else but
it's not coming oh obviously i watched
salt lake city um right and i started a
new book last night that's like a silly
rom commie book that i like literally i
read for 20 minutes and i'm like 30 and
you know the feeling let me know if you
like it because that definitely sounds
like something i would be into okay so
far so good it's called made in
manhattan m-a-d-e oh okay because i was
like copyright yeah
um so yes tv recap we have real
housewives of miami last night's
euphoria was literally like a
life-changing episode like i need to
talk about it we'll do it in the tv
recap it was life changing salt lake
city um
i watched the hating game and we don't
need to put it in the tv recap like it
was a cute movie like if you liked the
book you'll like the movie it was
exactly the same lucy hell was great it
wasn't like you know
a life-changing film that's gonna you
know
win oscars but it's cute
um
and i started the new colleen hoover
book
amazing look at you content queen yeah
the farm life is definitely for me yeah
everyone's talking about last night's
episode of euphoria so i look forward to
breaking that down so i can understand
like what shook the world so oh my god
it was quake where do you ever watch
something i used to feel this way when i
was younger and watched a lot of svu
when it gets like scary like your whole
body is watching and you're like have
such a pit and you have to remind
yourself like multiple times like it's a
tv show these are not real characters
this is not something that actually
happened it was so pit inducing and ben
never watches but he was like in bed
watching with me last night and he was
like is every episode like this i'm like
no like this is special unique
oh my god okay that's a lot it was a lot
okay wow and then also after friday's
episode wrapped like all this stuff came
out with kim and kanye so we have a lot
to recap in the fast five in unburden
yourselves in the tv recap and i just
think like we have to stop dilly
dallying and get right to it and get
right into it literally right after we
wrapped on friday we saw that kim
finally responded to kanye and
i was like
we could have like hopped back on and
recorded more but i'm actually glad that
we didn't because so much stuff has come
out since that like it requires a whole
monday morning debrief and that's what
we're here today yeah so without further
ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
blue land did you know that an estimated
five billion plastic hand soap and
cleaning bottles are thrown away each
year and if that's not bad enough each
bottle can be made of more than 90 water
it's a lose-lose situation for the
planet it's 20 22 stop wasting water and
throwing out more plastic and get blue
land's revolutionary refill cleaning
system instead blue lands ideas simple
and beautiful buy the bottle once refill
it forever no more plastic waste the
only thing you need to discard is your
outdated idea that eco-friendly products
are more expensive and less effective
you just fill the blue lands beautiful
instagramable bottles with warm water
pop in one of the hand soap or spray
cleaner tablets and within minutes you
have a powerful cleaning product in the
most incredible scents like iris agave
purine lemon sorry i just some french
and lavender eucalyptus
their stunning high quality forever
bottles start at just 10 when you buy a
kit and they are meant to be reused
forever with money-saving refill tablets
that start at just two dollars so it's a
no-brainer for you for the planet their
products smell so good they work super
effectively just as if not better than
toxic cleaning products and you're
helping the planet so i just don't
really understand why you wouldn't do it
right now you can get 20 off your first
order when you go to blueland.com
toast that's 20 off your first order of
any blueland products at blueland.com
toast
blueland.com
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by curology and i'm living for it
because i just got my new refill of
curology
so curology is a game-changing custom
skin care service made for you by a
dermatology provider they create a
custom subscription cream for your
specific goals whether that's tackling
acne clogged pores skin texture dark
spots fine lines or anything else you
start by taking a short online quiz and
uploading photos and if it's a good fit
they'll ship you your formula right to
your door it even has your name on the
bottle so what i love about curology
which is like groundbreaking but
shouldn't be i don't know why we've all
for like the last 100 years been using
the same skin products when we all have
different skin so curology whatever
comes in your box nobody else has it's
built for your skin and it's just so
smart it's really affordable and there's
just really in my opinion no reason not
to do it so i had to address i have
combination skin but in the winter i
have such dry skin and what i really
liked is when you take the quiz it's not
like just a basic quiz like they ask for
like unflattering photos of your face
from all different angles they get
really up close so they can see what's
actually going on with your skin and it
just feels like you're really getting
curated customized skin care so get
started with curology just like we did
with the 30 day trial at curology.com
toast you just pay the five dollars for
shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash toast to start your free
30-day trial cancel any time
and prescription is subject to
consultation
so just check it out winter is really a
tough time for people's skin and you
won't regret it
would you say curology is more personal
than comedy
i would i would say that yes
okay you'd love to see it curology more
personal than comedy that's their new
slogan free idea
okay first story update from last week
kim kardashian hit back at kanye west's
hurtful comments about north's tik tok
so as discussed last week kanye took to
instagram to talk about the fact that he
does not want his eight-year-old
daughter on tick-tock and who does he
need to reach out to or speak to to make
sure that this doesn't happen then in a
surprising twist of events kim responded
on instagram stories and she really
hasn't been responding to a lot of his
outcries so this was major she said
kanye's constant attacks on me in
interviews and on social media is
actually more hurtful than any tick tock
north might create as the parent who is
the main provider and caregiver for our
children i am doing my best to protect
our daughter while also allowing her to
express her creativity in the medium
that she wishes with adult supervision
because it brings her happiness deforest
is difficult enough on our children and
kanye's obsession with trying to control
and manipulate our situation so
negatively and publicly is only causing
further pain for all from the beginning
i have wanted nothing but a healthy and
supportive co-parenting relationship
because it's what's best for our
children and it makes me sad that connie
continues to make it impossible every
step of the way she said she wants to
handle all matters privately regarding
the children and hopefully he can
finally respond to the third attorney he
has had in the last year to solve any
issues amicably
so not only was this in my opinion a
perfect statement it was also a
groundbreaking moment because ever since
the divorce kim in
ups downs heislow's kanye saying things
she has never once responded i do
believe the only other time before they
got divorced she released a statement
when he was on his twitter rant just
being like you know dealing with someone
who suffers from a mental illness is
really difficult and we ask for privacy
at this time so this is like
groundbreaking because i think her
intention was to never handle anything
publicly co-parent for the kids remain
you know um
honorable and and all that but he pushed
her so hard and
and i think the implication that
kim is doing something that's not in the
best interest of their children is like
what really set her off because she's
such a good mom and i think wherever you
land on like should kids be on social
media it doesn't matter it's like an
issue that should be handled privately
between the mom and the dad like i don't
care what your opinion is what my
opinion is like it's not our child like
it doesn't matter
right and this is not the way to go
about it even if your message is totally
you know justified and on point yeah him
not wanting north on social media is a
reasonable thing that he should ask him
privately
yes then kanye has been posting all
weekend he has since deleted all of his
posts but there have been some um
you know bombshell ones he posted a
screenshot of her
statement and said what do you mean by
maine provider america so you try to
kidnap my daughter on her birthday by
not providing the address you put
security on me inside of the house to
play with my son then accuse me of
stealing i had to take a drug test after
chicago's party because you accused me
of being on drugs tracy romulus stopped
manipulating
kim to be this way
so this also harks back to remember a
few weeks ago when he was talking about
like kim's publicist and how she has
these people around her that he's like
not here for and we tried to like
explain away that it wasn't tracy and
then it's probably some rogue publicist
who she hired a third party
but uh it's tracy
yeah and the thing is is you know this
is obviously very reminiscent of kanye's
twitter rants where he would say crazy
things delete them and i always um
associate his you know odd behavior on
social media for someone who never posts
ever on social media with you know him
struggling
with with some of the stuff that he goes
through
so i don't know i do feel weird like
living for this like oh look steph
chef's husband was the one who gave
kanye kim's number like i and i see
people like commenting on it being like
oh my god crazy it makes me very sad it
really does and i hope that
for what i i my perception of this whole
thing for what i believe to be going
down like i just hope everyone can find
peace because
this isn't like fun drama or gossip it's
like no it's sad it's sad uh it's very
sad i do feel for kim i'm sure this is
an incredibly like frustrating situation
for her and i think also for kanye also
i just wanted to clear up because i
think last week when we were assuming
that kanye didn't want north on
tick-tock it was like because of like
being in the public eye and he was like
well he we were like well he put her on
stage at his show and blah blah blah but
um i think it's more to do with and
something else that we spoke about last
week unrelated with like the damaging
effects of social media like on children
and especially young girls which is like
a different conversation i do think that
like tick tock interviews a lot to it so
i think while you know his message um
for a lot of people is extremely
fair the delivery is
piss poor as bad as it gets
and it's just not on us to have an
opinion on how they parent their
children and so him putting it in the
public discourse makes everyone think
that they have an opinion that people
give a [ __ ] about i don't care what your
philosophy on social media is for your
kids i will handle it my way you handle
it your way and kim and kanye can handle
it how they see fit so i just
i just feel like this whole story gives
me a pit and it just makes me feel you
know reminiscent of other times where
he's been acting out on social media and
what implications that has on his mental
health
yeah no it definitely gives me a pit and
it's someone who was like you know
my ship was leveled because i thought
that they were in a good spot and
co-parenting well and everyone was doing
like what was best and happiest for them
this is uh like a sad for the kimier
stands who we're still holding on
not to the hope of a romantic
relationship but just to like this
family unit like this is really
not good
you know it's not and i think when we
all like gossip about it and post about
it we should just keep that in mind you
know like
this is someone's family it's someone's
mental health and it's not like fun
gossip it's
it's sad
yeah agreed but we have some happy
kardashian news
which is that kylie jenner has welcomed
a baby boy with travis scott she posted
last night on instagram
a photo black and white photo of baby's
hand and i'm assuming stormy's hand with
a blue heart saying 2 2 22 and that's
all we've got for sure and chris posted
that she has a grandson so we know it's
a boy plus it was a blue heart and now
it's time for name speculation and the
there's a lot of of like strong guesses
theories coming through yeah
so i would like to throw my weight
behind this one particular theory that i
saw on tick-tock i do not claim that i
invented this i did not people on
tick-tock are saying it because a lot of
the emojis and like the things coming
out of the baby shower
were like heavy use of the word angel
now i don't think that the baby's name
is angel but now a lot of people on tick
tock are you know coming up with angel
like names heaven halo so i'm thinking
something in the angelic realm
okay that's a good guess
the names that are coming out also i saw
last week that people think it's
valentine no i don't think so
i don't think it's that either that's
like a name from poldark so maybe she
was also watching
um and that could have inspired her but
there was one name that's like sort of
making the rounds but i it's not as
strong i guess as the others which is
sunny
and i think that could be it because it
would go really well with stormy
yeah but remember when kim head north
and then we thought like the next one
would be like east yeah
but it's not i don't it's not like
stormy and rainy like it's first of all
it's their sun and it's sunny and then
it also like they they go nicely i think
it's a possibility
i i think it's a possibility but i'm not
convinced like and you know what i think
what kylie comes with is going to be
something no one has thought of because
that's so kylie and you know what else
is so kindly like she's just so
effortlessly naturally cool like of
course her child would be born 2 22
which is like a date i'm sure a million
people tried to get married on it's like
a cool day yeah yeah
and it's the day after stormy's birthday
which is just crazy
such a crazy coincidence also courtney
had mason and rain on the same day five
years apart
oh that's cute isn't that interesting
yeah the odds when do you think we're
gonna find out the name the odds are one
in three hundred and sixty-five
[Music]
i think we're going to find out the name
i don't know i'm ready for it though
kylie please like we need this
it's killing you yeah like
we we need something to live for like
please
yeah no i when i saw last night even
then she like announced that she gave
birth like it was just so exciting and
even though like we all knew she was
giving birth any day now still so
shocking
you know what's so interesting about
kylie too when you compare her to
pregnancies is like
the first time around she was like
really not newly famous but it was like
coming off the heels of this crazy
success she was like the you know the
first self-made billionaire youngest
whatever and she was like you know they
had the vlog and it was this whole thing
and now she's just so chill because like
i think she's in a really good place and
she's like yeah we had a baby no big
ta-dah just yeah we had a baby yeah
maybe there will be a big tadada with
the name like obviously there has to be
more content coming i just um and i'm
sure she's extremely busy but if she
could just get it on that name thing for
us that would be really really right
and she's just so chill like she had the
baby on the second and she told us on
the six and i'm sure she'd be in the
hospital for a few days like she's just
like being a cool girl
yeah
she's not like other girls
no
no she is not
so very exciting i'm really curious to
know what the name is and i i don't
think anybody has guessed it i don't
think it's angel and i don't think it's
heaven
and halo or anything like that but i i
understand why people do you know what
else i saw so she posted like a bunch of
the flowers that she got and i was i
like screenshotted zoomed in
me too and it was from kim north st it
was from the kardashian west crew
and
i thought it was kind of isn't like a
really formal weird thing to do like for
your sister like go to her house and say
congrats yeah i guess i thought imagine
if i sent you flowers like well first of
all i thought the card was like so
formal and then second of all i was like
am i can i expect flowers for my sisters
that would be so nice to have all these
flowers in my house
if you want like i can arrange that but
i wasn't planning on it like i think it
would be nice that's something like
that's something your accountant does
yeah i know but they they send each
other flowers for everything and it's
not just like flowers it's a whole thing
but you know what it also might they
love flowers
it would be nice but flowers are a lot
of maintenance like when you're just you
know a regular person and you're keeping
them in your house and they're not like
forever roses
i don't know if like i'm foreign having
to keep like
all these things going on i don't know
if i can deal with flowers
no i know it's like it's a full-time job
being a florist a botanist if you will
it's a full-time job having like plants
and flowers in your house yes 100 and
then they like get smelly if you forget
to water them for one day depending on
how cheap they are like it's just like
it's and then the petals fall over the
floor and like theo eats them and they
have to sweep them up like it sucks the
smell is deadly but it is the smell of
death like the flowers have died i'll
never
i'll never forget the first time i
smelled like a truly dead flower because
i didn't know i thought like okay
flowers wilt and maybe they lose their
delicious smell but they don't you know
turn to poison decay
yeah yeah and so i was shook i'm like
what the [ __ ] is that smell in my house
and i'm sniffing all over and i'm like
the flowers it was just like the most
mind-boggling thing to me
that is funny i don't think that the
kardashian flowers go bad like that
speaking of decay i did finish that um
documentary taken at birth um and i just
want to say i did recommend it but at
the end i realized they like gaslet us
the whole time they had all these
theories and uh none of them turned out
to be true and i was just like why did
we watch a six-hour documentary like we
got we got like nothing
interesting i tried to start this tinder
swindler because you made it sound
really good and i just i couldn't get
i couldn't get into it
okay except for everyone but i watched
um there's an american greed episode
about elizabeth holmes you should watch
it because it's one hour and it'll
explain to you the situation
and uh the only thing that i took away
from it from the half hour that i
watched um which i thought you might
find interesting is that her fans who
like just think she's a girl boss who's
being mistreated they're called the
homies
oh i'm such a homie i'm gonna add that
to my instagram bio hashtag homie swifty
homey and lobotic
perfect i thought you might like that i
thought it was cute also this doesn't
really need to go in the tv recap but i
did watch the most bizarre documentary
series it's like a national geographic
series called um locked up abroad and
they have people come it's an hour long
episode and they tell the story of the
time that they were put in jail abroad
and then they also have like actors like
dramatize it
while like the person who actually went
through it narrates and it is the most
craziest thing it was on hulu and i just
want to say if anyone listening to this
podcast has ever thought like you know
what
i'll do it one time i'll make five
thousand dollars let me smuggle drugs
from peru
do not do it and the first rule of
smuggling drugs is not on your body not
on your body everyone knows that okay
just do not do it where do you do it
then so a lot of people have the drugs
like
metastasized to like different i don't
know if that's right word but like
different substances and then they line
the bottom of their suitcase with it and
it can go through security totally fine
unless you know you get pulled aside
special you know but
some dumb people like duct tape it to
their body and then they put on like
huge sweatshirts and so they're walking
through the
the airport like with enormous
sweatshirts and sweatpants on like two
two girls two young girls wearing huge
hoodies and huge wet pants oh that's not
obvious
don't that's what people wear these days
no like you should have seen the
dramatization they looked so stupid like
i would have arrested them in a second
interesting okay
it's a really good show oh you would
recommend it yes especially the one um
about the woman
who has a daughter and she smuggles
drugs in i want to say ecuador
and she ends up in ecuadorian prison for
five years falls in love and gets
married in prison has a baby and then
like right when she finds out she's
pregnant her appeal goes through and she
has to go back to the states and leave
her husband slash baby daddy in the
prison
sounds like a hallmark movie so good it
sounds like a lifetime movie
100
100
okay are you ready for our next story
is it the next story that happens to be
brought to you by fuzzy
yes
if you have a pet you know they're a
part of your family i mean brew daddu
magu you know and fuzzy knows that
there's nothing that compares to coming
home to a wiggle butt or waking up to
soft purrs and that we want to keep our
pets healthy and make them as happy as
they make us so fuzzy is a telehealth
service for pet parents that offers 24 7
access to personalized pet care from vet
from veterinary professionals
from everyday questions to middle of the
night emergencies fuzzy has the answers
every pet parent needs through live chat
virtual vet consultations available to
you 24 hours a day seven days a week
fuzzy can answer your pet questions big
and small urgent and every day
so i have fuzzy because our vet dr lisa
told me about it and it is life-changing
just to know like i i used to not know
what to do like if theo ate something or
he was like acting weird you feel so
helpless so just having an app you can
get in contact with someone
so fast it just is peace of mind really
like you can't put a price on but fuzzy
is putting a price on it and right now
they're offering our listeners a free
seven-day trial membership if you go to
yourfuzzy.com toast today to sign up so
it's a free seven-day trial at
y-o-u-r-f-u-z-y
dot com slash toast and for a limited
time fuzzy is all for also offering
a special discount of 20 off any of your
pet product needs so that's meds
supplements food and more when you use
the promo code toast so that's
yourfuzzy.comtoast for your free trial
of fuzzy with access to 24 7
personalized pet care and vet
recommended products and just trust and
believe like nothing is more important
to us than the health and safety of our
pets and i trust fuzzy and so should you
trust and believe
trust and believe our next story a
fellow pet lover queen elizabeth is
shocking the world as she backs camilla
as queen consort in a new statement so
first of all it's the queen
platinum jubilee 70 years anniversary of
her on the throne so there's just like a
lot of celebration a lot of queen news
is she the longest reigning monarch she
is the longest reigning monarch which is
very exciting she put out a letter the
majority of which thinks her subjects
and remarks on the progress made during
her reign but near the end she dropped
what many consider to be a bomb she said
quote i remain eternally grateful for
and humbled by the loyalty and affection
you continue to give me and when in the
fullness of my time my son charles
becomes king i know you will give him
and his wife camilla the same support
that you have given me and it is i don't
think so
this is nice i don't think that i will
and it is my sincere wish that when the
time comes camilla will be known as
queen consort as she continues her own
loyal service so this was a big deal
because even though it's like impossible
a lot of people are fully like convinced
that she will have you know charles
abdicate because he sucks and is hated
by everyone and william who comes next
is like so beloved by the nation and it
seems like a no-brainer but i guess
that's not how it works and she's now
fully confirmed that like charles is
gonna be king well most people were i
mean for me that was the surprising part
that like she's telling us like she's
not skipping charles like i literally
i really believed in my soul that she
would find a way to skip him that she
knows that like he's not it and that the
future like if you wanna
the monarchy is it's already like it's
always in peril and if like we need a
fresh start and we need to modernize and
like nobody's here for charles we can
all agree on that so i just thought that
perhaps there was a chance so that's
what's most shocking to me and she's
like no charles is next in line like
don't get it twisted and most people are
extremely shocked that camilla will be
known as queen
but i mean if he is gonna be king then
yeah she would be his queen that doesn't
shock me as much
well like that's the whole part i
actually don't understand like how
philip was a prince
okay i finally understand it okay
because a king outranks a queen every
time so if philip were to become king
then he would outrank his wife who is
the monarch and that's just not gonna
happen got it okay so he had to remain a
prince so that she could be the number
one girl in this group so basically the
the person who married him is only going
to get the king or queen title if it's a
woman
yeah that rocks
yeah finally women succeeding out front
of men
yes so that's why camilla could be queen
and it's not like she's an actual queen
like queenie because she's a king she's
just like not a queen i can't explain it
like she doesn't give off queenie vibes
whatsoever and i just like i see kate as
a queen like i do i think the nation
loves her i don't see camilla as a queen
now i think that if camilla and charles
were to mysteriously disappear this
might be queenie covering her tracks
being like no he was supposed to be
kicked oh interesting as if it's like
i'm certain tension i'm still holding on
to hope i'm holding on to hope too and
as far as camilla like people really are
hey hi camilla hate i personally i don't
hate i don't feel strongly one way or
the other and what like just saddens me
is like when you watch the crown or you
know the story of like charles and
camilla and like they should have gotten
married first and yes they didn't just
because she wasn't a virgin so like they
brought diana into it they ruined so
many people's lives and like marriages
and happinesses
because she wasn't a virgin and like but
uh but other than that like she was a
completely like suitable choice or she
was like a little bit older than him too
and she's a little like i guess you know
uh wild why right but like in hindsight
if you just let these two get married
they're clearly otp they love each other
so much even in their [ __ ] 70s yeah
it would have been a completely
different story no they would have loved
loved loved camilla like they would have
gotten past it would have taken a little
time to get past like ooh she's had sex
with a man like they would have gotten
over it and then they would have just
like come to love and their love is real
like it is it's not one of these
arranged marriages so people would have
loved it and it's you're right it's like
what's that phrase you know
pennies and and nickels you know like
save a penny
um like when you do something in the
short term and like you're not thinking
long term yeah it's definitely pennies
what's the phrase um a penny short
dollar no no it's like save a penny
spend it on it save a penny right i
don't know boy check it i keep thinking
save a horse ride a cowboy also now what
is the phrase a day late a dollar short
oh maybe i'm miss thinking mis
representing cutting off your nose
despite your face
kind of kind of like that whatever
you just let me know in the comments
what phrase what phrase you think
applies i think pennies and nickels
there is a phrase here
there's always there's a phrase here do
you not agree for sure
this is quintessential phrase dumb
yeah no there's lessons to be learned
here and i feel like even in watching
poldark it's always this way it's like
just let the people marry who they
wanted to marry because you're going to
get into a big mess otherwise drama yeah
so
those are my thoughts on that but then
also you could say like if it didn't go
this way then we wouldn't have william
and harry and et cetera et cetera
that's true yeah
so
whatever
that's the latest with the royals queen
camilla is
apparently allegedly on the horizon
i'll believe it when i see it which is
less shocking than king charles cavalier
spaniel yeah you know maybe i could get
behind it after all king charles
only if they
like you know how every the queen has
like a a breed of dog she's obsessed
with if king charles doesn't have king
charles is um then i'm officially done
with his family no as if i could hate
him more i agree if he doesn't have king
charles it's good day sir
good day sir goodbye okay that's that
seems like a fair
test yeah
are you for ready for our next story two
of your favorite people actually this
story has every element of a story for
you
really yes
andy cohen received the hollywood walk
of fame star he was honored by john
mayer and the woman who came up to this
fell to presented to him fell okay i
thought there were so many interesting
things about this um
ceremony what i was surprised andy
didn't have a a star already but he
totally deserves it two i thought the
housewives who were chosen to be there
were interesting i only saw garcelle and
lisa rinna which i just found
to be just interesting maybe it's
because they both live in l.a and we're
available yeah
um
and i just loved that john mayer was
there and i have to say in real
housewives of miami i despise nicole and
when she said her um
hall pass would be john mayer that was
like the only time i related to her in
like the smallest sense
um john mayer's speech was hilarious you
know riddled with housewives analogies
he's obviously really into housewives i
just want to say nicole definitely said
that john mayer thing because she knows
like andy and john and like john might
see that like she's a thirst monster 100
percent but so interesting
do you really think john watches real
housewives like that or he had a ghost
writer
i think he dabbles i don't think he
keeps up like we do no but i but he obvi
he made that like lisa barlow heather
gay joke which is like extremely recent
um niche so then he must keep up but
when he goes on watch rap inside like
does he play housewives trivia i nev i
never thought about it i just thought he
was andy's friend i didn't think he was
a housewives like super fan
i feel like he only he became a
housewife superfan after the baby shower
like i think at first he was like oh
this is what my friend andy does and
then he had so much fun with the ladies
and then like john mellencamp's daughter
was there and i think he was like this
is just my theory like i'm just
hypothesizing i think that that was a
catalyst for him to be like oh maybe i
should get into this interesting i think
that he had a ghostwriter who's
obviously like not um watching salt lake
city with the same set of eyes that we
are and how like of all the friendships
on real housewives
period like the fact that you think
heather gay is like the friend of all
friends um
i find to be extreme it's just
mind-boggling extremely suspicious
so i actually i didn't i didn't enjoy i
didn't enjoy the content of his speech
the woman presenting the star to andy
when she got up on stage she missed a
step and she completely ate [ __ ] and she
handled it with grace
kindness and elegance she acknowledged
the falls i think she said like who
cares my dress is from old navy i think
she said something like that like she
made a funny joke
she handled it with elegance and you
know what i respect her for it and not
only do i respect her i sympathize with
her
so wholeheartedly i think she wrote into
unburdening yourself today to share her
story
so well then we're going to help her
through that yeah no she she did um
sail past it quite elegantly
but of course it made up as elegant as
one could it made everyone think of you
yeah which i'm not like super pleased
about i can't lie
you've embraced myself a lot that's what
people associate with me yeah no i've
been a little too honest with you guys i
agree you gotta play closer to the chest
to the vest or to the chest
vest
vest
okay
do you think like the the timing in
which they decide to give people stars
on on the walk of fame like makes no
sense
yeah when i saw the first picture of him
getting his star i just assumed it was
like a throwback picture like what was
the second what like what i don't
understand it's such a weird
thing and everyone's like so weird gets
it like not at the cu i mean i guess you
have to be like extremely established
for a long time to be like that iconic
to be on the walk not like uh as you're
ascending or even when you're at the
like you need
time spent at the top so by the time you
do get it it's years duh
how did you not have one before yeah
that's true
but every time i see someone getting
their star i'm like they just got it
yeah
yeah
shook
are you ready for a fifth and final
story it's another claudius choice for
sure
oh yeah i'm ready
nyu launches a new course about taylor
swift for the 2022 spring semester
new york university's clive davis
institute has officially launched a
brand new course on taylor swift for its
spring semester variety reports
quote this course proposes to
deconstruct both the appeal and
aversions to taylor swift through close
readings of her music and public
discourse as it relates to her own
growth as an artist and a celebrity the
course description reads
what are your so i just want to say
okay like obviously nyu did something
like cool 10 years after i graduated and
i had to sit through the loserville
population us at nyu people at nyu are
like so averse to like mainstream things
like if you're not wearing a beanie and
like drinking an iced chai with you know
non-gmo milk like they're not interested
in you so i have a feeling i could see
nobody signing up for this class first
of all
second of all it's in the clive davis
music school which is like a really
really small program it's where maggie
rogers was discovered it's extremely
prestigious so it's not really like
anyone can sign up for this class if
you've been through like the class
signups you know how crazy it is so this
is gonna no one no one who like is a
taylor swift like mega fan who just goes
to like regular like the liberal arts
program is going to be able oh sorry is
going to be able to get into this
program
and i just want to say reading the
course description it really should be
in like the psychology major because
it's not like they're talking about her
music or like her
lyrics they're like well the aversion
and the obsession it's really like a
psychology course
i guess sociology okay you explaining
that it's part of clive davis and like
that it's this small school of full of
like music experts and i'm sure there
are other classes similar to this about
other artists but because like it's
taylor swift and it's new like it's
making news it made news but before you
just shared that like i just thought
this was extremely uh moronic it's like
just go on tumblr like
it's
like it's so silly like 55 000 a year to
learn about taylor swift what from a
professor who doesn't know her like
doesn't know more about her than anyone
else can seek out
this is the
ruse and the manipulation that is
college education the most useless
waste of money 100 like imagine sending
your kid working so hard your whole life
sending your kid to get a great
education at nyu and they come home and
they're doing taylor swift homework no
discredit to taylor swift but
it's just so like it's it's so college
like it's so dumb it's so dumb like and
this is not me saying anything bad about
taylor swift
i agree not even close but like where
are the useful skills like you can spend
like you could spend your whole day on
like tumblr instagram like going through
taylor swift's like concert dvds and and
that's and get the course and you could
write a thesis but like what are we
teaching the children teach them
something it makes sense because it's in
the the music program so yes so yes i
agree with you but um i just think
overall like what does this
say about college i just think college
is so dumb like i can't
i'm dumber by the day i'm super grateful
for like the opportunity to have had a
higher education and everyone who went
to college is
very very like lucky and blessed but i
just think in the real world like
there's nothing really that you learn at
college that you can't learn like just
being a human being out working
meeting like
there's really no tangible in my opinion
unless you're going like law school med
school i don't come for me because i
respect higher education i do i just
think that like
i really can't pinpoint something i
learned in college that helped me in the
real world i'm being dead serious yeah i
have a few different thoughts on this
and i i agree with you if you're in a
specialized field yes it is extremely
critical nutritionist yes
the doctor scientist bio engineer like
we're not talking about we're not
talking about you um no but you're
talking about like the broader liberal
arts education where you can take a
class like taylor swift's rise and what
it means for society yeah yeah
nonsense i think a lot of what is
learned in
college is nonsense but i do think the
the practice of like going to college
like you you are a teenager when you
arrive and it's like it's kind of like
this buffer where by the time you emerge
like you're able to be on your own like
ecology you're on your own but you're
not really there are all of these like
things in place like you know you're
living by yourself but it's like a dorm
and there you're going to get your own
food but it's a meal plan and it's like
halfway to adulthood and i think it's a
great transition
for people to transition and i think
also for a lot of people like working
especially in a lot of like books that
i've read like
especially non-fiction books like
working to get to college can completely
free you from whatever circumstances
you were born into and and the world
then becomes your oyster like think of
the show made
right like the opportunities you get
well that's just like a [ __ ] up part
of it right that's a [ __ ] up part of
society a hundred percent but like you
can have gone to college and not gone to
college and one doesn't make you smarter
than the other like this
i'm talking about like the emphasis we
put on having a college degree in order
to get good jobs like and i'm not saying
doctors of course doctors need to go to
school like please stay
but
just like the emphasis we put on college
and also the way it's like not equally
available to everyone it's just we're
setting everyone up for failure right i
completely agree and then you also
get into the conversation of like you
know elite institutions and like the
college admissions scandal corruption
there's thousands of colleges in the
country yet everybody's fighting and
clamoring to get into these few where by
the way you can learn about taylor swift
there it's just it's silliness and i
agree with like the the structure itself
and the fact that you know there's only
so much you can do if you don't go to
college
that system is like setting people up
for failure people who don't have access
to higher education yes but but also the
system like it it has afforded a lot of
people like opportunities
tickets out yeah but it's like why can't
you get that ticket
otherwise yeah no i just think the
emphasis society puts on college is so
stupid like because you can really do
anything and it doesn't matter if you
have a college degree or not depends on
what you're doing yes yeah
yeah was that a hot take
i'm sure yeah but we've said that before
yeah and i'm not saying i just respect
higher education academia the scholars i
don't i respect you what you do is
empowering and important i just think
like the system in which we like
discredit people who don't have college
degrees when in the end like i'm not
that much more different because i went
to college right when a lot of college
degrees
some college degrees are worthless
agreed mine
well those are the fast five you
absolutely needed to know them we have
so much more to discuss um but those
were the fastest stories and
next what are we doing next claude
what's program have in store for us well
so you i think we should do unburden
yourselves because
in case anyone didn't watch euphoria we
will put all the tv recap at the end of
the show and we'll just quickly unburden
ourselves great okay that sounds like a
plan
okay this first one is so funny okay
ready
hello jackie and claudia i'm so happy to
hear about this new segment you're doing
because while the subject of this burden
is small the embarrassment around it is
certainly anything but
i'm in a group chat with two of my
co-workers who are a few years older
than me they're both married
30-something men
while we've become great friends through
work who hang out fairly often there
still is this unspoken boundary between
the three of us considering my
relationship with them is rooted in work
the two of them were discussing
something in the group chat that i
didn't understand i sent them a screen
recording of me googling the topic to
show how clueless i was to it while i
was trying to make a joke around their
topic of discussion i ended up being an
even bigger one at the top of the video
when i was searching in google all my
previous google searches populated
briefly while i was typing out what i
had intended
since i was recording the video and the
drop down was quick i didn't even
realize you could see it after sending
the video one of the guys responded are
we going to discuss
why is my poo small rocks
which unfortunately which was one of my
google searches along with a lengthy
list of other mortifying other searches
she sent me a screenshot
i had been caught red-handed that i
couldn't even deny it or come up with a
decent lie
they send me ads for metamucil now and
on my desk they love a packet of pop
rocks but taped a small over the top of
the title so she sent me a screenshot
here are her other google search
ferragamo loafers okay tao chicago
free people
waco miniseries obviously she was
watching the toast
reindeer boob
why is my poo small rocks
mini credit card
okay everything is fine what's a
reindeer boob but um why is she wanted
to see what it
so this isn't an advice segment but if
you were asking for our advice you
obviously need to leave your job leave
the state um maybe the country that is
so embarrassing except i it could be
worse because it could have been like
why am i having raging diarrhea like at
least like small rocks poop is like
girly poop it's like you're so like
you're so dainty and cute like you can't
even make a poop because you're such a
cute little
girl so it's like if they i guess they
knew already that you poop technically
so it's like and you have a small rocks
poop
if they had to imagine you poop at least
they're not imagining you like sweating
totally naked on the toilet like crying
terrible pain like screaming for help
like and now when they envision you
they're like oh she's so cute she can't
even make like a full poop
screaming for
help
yeah like i always say like don't ever
be nervous in front of anyone because
like everyone has had moments where they
are completely naked sweating like an
animal crying screaming for help on the
toilet like that happens to everyone
even shawn mendes so you know what at
least the picture they have of you
pooping is not the sean mendes picture
it's just like cute little like i don't
even poop
i think this is great i'm happy for you
congratulations and you know what
they're gonna be so much worse
it could always be worse i've ever
googled you need to remember it can
always be worse and here's the silver
lining at least it was small rocks poop
no like big turd
sweaty shawn mendes gurley
how to unblock
oh that's funny oh my god
yeah like there's just so much other
are you okay
oh yeah i'm kind of like
i'm gonna pee in my pants you're
literally gonna go into labor
yeah someone once said i'm gonna go into
labor from laughing on the toast and
this is the kind of laugh that could do
it
oh my god but you know what we're giving
sage advice like it's gonna be
gonna be okay
i feel i feel like but if you've had a
laugh about this
then you can move on
we i need to move on you know what at
least
i need to move on or my water's gone
well as expected like most of our
submissions are about pooping i don't
know why but that seems to be the thing
that most people have associated with
shame
hello jackson claude how you doing
end up
first i just wanted to say that i love
you both so much you ladies are truly
the best part of my day when i heard
about this new segment i knew i had to
write in
now for the unburdening i have a duty
secret that gives me the biggest pit
it was last friday when i was making my
way back to school after a wonderful
toasty winter break hold on i need to uh
this font it's like i need my glasses
i'm getting so old
okay
it was last friday when i was making my
way back to school after a wonderful
toasty winter break when my stomach
started to rumble
i was already about halfway back to
school so i figured i would just make it
through the last 45 minutes of the drive
without having to stop and in my favor
my stomach did settle down fast forward
and i'm about 10 minutes away from
school and my stomach starts to rumble
again but this time it's urgent i'm on
the main road into the school but there
are only farms thanks again central
pennsylvania and there's no bathrooms in
sight at this point
i'm about to duty in my pants so i do
what i had to do and i pulled over
grabbed some antibacterial wipes ran
around to the side of the car and waited
for some cars to pass squatted and took
a duty
right there on the side of the road even
just writing this tuke is giving me the
biggest pit but i did what had to be
done and this will be the one secret
that i take to my grave sincerely a
shameful duty toaster
i mean lesson learned next time stop
while there's places to be stopped at
least like you did it it's done it's
farmland so they'll just think it was an
animal yeah and they're not they're used
to seeing like you know poops abound and
nobody saw you it sounds like so
just make sure you the right lessons are
learned here and then it's not a mistake
if you've if you learn something and you
know what you have actually inspired me
to unburden something that i did this
weekend
oh my god what did you do it's really
bad i wasn't even gonna bring it up
because i think it's technically like a
crime
okay you wanna are you sure you wanna
bring it up
yeah we can always cut it out
okay
what the [ __ ] did you do so we went to
wawa on our way home and i had to pee
so
bad
and they wouldn't let me use the
bathroom i was like screaming i'm like
please
so
i get back to the uber i'm on the i'm on
the
the seat behind the driver and we pulled
up on the right so my door is in the
road not on the curb
and it was like four in the morning and
it was like a a main road but it was
mostly empty so i just pulled my pants
down i leaned my back against the
passenger door and i squatted like i was
on a toilet and i just peed in the
middle of the street
oh okay
so
yeah technically like peeing in public
is um a crime no but i actually think it
well it depends where you are on the
city yeah like in the city you can do it
these days
and yeah no i see people doing it all
the time in the city and if i had to be
subjected to like one more scary man
whipping out his penis and peeing in a
water bottle by a pay phone i think that
i'm entitled to relieve myself at four
in the morning on an empty street when
i'm in a lot of pain it was a medical
emergency at this point
got it okay sounds like you took care of
business
all right this next one is it's harmless
i think honestly
and that's the final one sorry first off
obsessed with the toast you guys make my
day every day now let the unburdening
begin
last night i was out at a bar in new
york city and i made the cardinal sin of
leaving my jacket on the coat rack
because this place had no coat check
when i was leaving my friends and i were
grabbing our coats to go out into the
tundra when i noticed that my expensive
coat was of course the only one missing
from the rack in true tipsy girl fashion
i decided to remove all the coats from
the rack and place them on the floor if
they didn't resemble my missing jacket i
was calling it process of elimination
but the bouncer called it grounds for
termination i haven't been kicked out of
a bar since i was 21 and i just felt the
need to get this off my chest p.s it
turns out a girl stole my coat and was
hiding it under her table while watching
the whole debacle it's a harsh world
oh well i hope that means that you got
it back and up until like knowing where
it went i would assume that someone had
left with it like that's [ __ ]
infuriating especially when you're drunk
and you're at the end of the night and
it's like
your emotions are are flared up due to
alcohol and you're cold and you want to
leave it's really annoying to have your
coat stolen but i really hope that you
got it back in that in some way this
girl got hers
no but there's like a lot of shame with
being kicked out of a bar i was kicked
out of a bar like about a year ago and
it was like one of the worst nights of
my life like it's so shameful you just
feel like a vagrant like
and no like what you're just being like
a menace you're usually you obviously
can get kicked out of a bar for like
starting fights but like i feel like
most of the time it's like you're just
being like an [ __ ] because you're
drunk and you're like yelling at people
um and it's like embarrassing i got um
kicked out of a bar about a year ago for
puffing a jewel like they had a no jewel
policy and like i even get a second
chance that's not embarrassing then it
was no it was harmless and that's why i
was like so i the problem was is that i
got kicked out and i snuck back in
and then the guy found me while i was
waiting in line for the bathroom and he
was like didn't i kick you out and i was
like so wasted i was like
do i know you
i was like what are you talking about no
i just got here that doesn't sound like
a bar worth going to you can't have a
[ __ ] jewel it's a really fun bar i'm
not gonna lie
but i don't want to name it because i
don't want to associate myself like as
the girl who got kicked out of it you
know got it got it and i love that bar
and i just want to say if anyone who
owns the bar who knows what i'm talking
about like i would love to come back
please yeah and they rethink your jewel
policy yeah i mean like
worse things go down in a bar 100
um so that was unburdened yourselves and
you know what it was a great kick off to
our new segment if you want to shoot us
an email it's unburdened yourselves
it's plural because we couldn't get
access to the other one it's unburden
yourselves
gmail.com
and i enjoyed that very much me too
and now i think we can officially dive
into the tv recap which is brought to
you by jenny kane
jenny kane home creates california
inspired classics for any room or mood
they're grounded in natural textures and
inviting neutrals they are the pieces
you'll love coming home to
so their pacific bed the linen um and
busil i don't know if i'm pronouncing
that correctly but finding the perfect
perfect bed can be tough because you
want to be elevated yet enduring and
able to evolve with any design choice
and that's where the pacific bed from
jenny kane home comes in with classic
colors like ivory and charcoal and
timeless fabrics that work with any
bedroom style the pacific bed is a piece
you'll have for years to come and it's
available in natural linen ivory linen
charcoal linen and ivory wool bounce i
feel like this style's really in trend
right now
and jenny came home makes like really
good quality pieces of furniture because
sometimes when you're buying furniture
you really don't know how it's made
jenny kane is like a legit good
reputable brand and all their pieces are
really really well made like their
brentwood chair which comes in ivory and
natural the handcrafted accent chair
that everyone is obsessed with it's
perfect for your bedroom living room the
den
and it's available in two shades ivory
wool busil um and if you can't get
enough of jenny kane join jenny kane
rewards exclusive perks benefits like
birthday surprises and early access to
new launches plus you can earn up to 10
back on all purchases join today and
you'll get 100 points so create the
space you'll never want to leave at
jennycaine.com and get 15 off your first
order when you use code toast at
checkout that's 15 off your first order
at j e n n i
k-a-y-n-e dot com promo code toast
all right should we start with miami
yes
so i really enjoyed it i agree with all
your sentiments from the beginning of
the show i think it's beautifully done i
think they cast it really well um
personally like i definitely gravitate
towards marisol and alexia and i know
that that might be a toxic choice
because like in the in montauk marisolic
was being toxic but she had this
information and she just went about
sharing it in like such a bad way almost
like a mean girl by like who do you
trust the least like that's stupid if
you have this information just share
with everyone like don't be embarrassed
share it
yeah i agree i'm not like completely
here for marisol and alexia like i do
think that they're kind of mean girls
but i think that they're like great
housewives they're just like not my
um
cup of tea necessarily i still am a
larson stan i i like really just like
her energy she just seems like a funny
person to be around calm too yeah like
very calm and just like smart and sure
of herself and watching this like really
made me sad that her and kim are no
longer friends and it's so funny because
like so many of like her mannerisms are
just the things that she says remind me
of kim and i could see how you know they
got along at one point because they're
both like have just that same energy of
just calmness
and a little bit of shade yeah and i i
mean like i wish i hope that one day
they could be friends again but i don't
know what happened and i doubt we ever
will and i don't think that there's any
coming back from it for her and i think
she knows that and so she took her
talents to miami
to miami i'm also was really surprised
to learn that her and scottie pippen are
still technically married i did not know
that i thought they'd been divorced for
like 100 years yeah and the me too i
just assumed that they had like divorced
even before she was on real housewives
season one
and i think that they're like their life
is so interesting and i mean their kids
are so cute but the fact that they still
even have like their childhood home and
that like larsa is living there it's
just like so
so crazy the whole situation also her
only fans it's
one great storyline for
housewives um
and that the fact that like everyone's
like fighting and it's interesting to
see like the way that people treat it
you can like learn a lot from them i
thought alexia was being like so awful
about so judgmental first pool party and
a lot of the other women were more
open-minded and it's not as if like
larsa like does it in secret or like
didn't tell the other women and like
someone found it like she's very open
about it and um
just like who cares who i mean who cares
but like
yeah that was a bad moment for alexia
like really bad who [ __ ] cares yeah
and then like adriana like coming over
and wanting to like sell feed picks for
200 and like literally pathetic it was
giving vanderpump rules feet for nose
picks well i think we should talk about
adriana because you know in the og
seasons she was a a top tier one of my
favorites heavy hitter and now knowing
that she's not even a housewife she's i
guess she's considered a friend of
because she's not holding an apple at
the beginning she doesn't have a tagline
um but she's
making such an effort like to get
attention and be like crazy get in the
tub with my titties out and knowing that
she didn't even become a housewife it
puts this like kind of sad spin on
everything she does i'm like she
obviously wanted to be back on the show
so bad she's trying to make a moment out
of everything and it didn't even work
there's so much sadness surrounding
everything that she's doing and like
desperation and even like the the
situation with the rooms which was like
such a it was probably like peak rooms
on a trip housewives situation yeah and
it became this like big fight and it's
like the person who like got naked in
the master suite took a bath and poured
water and everyone like still can't get
arrested it was about lisa it's not even
close to about yeah like it's about lisa
just for having an attitude when it's
like literally nobody cares what adriana
does or says and also even her
relationship with julian having like
such disrespect like for her marriage it
just is so thirsty and weird and i also
like even when she like came for gertie
at the
party and also when um they were party
planning and gertie and julia were both
opening up about their experiences like
her reaction i thought to gertie was
like so
cold and it just everything she does
with julia she's so weird everything she
does is just like the wrong take
it's just wrong and i agree and it's he
made even more sad by the fact that at
one point like she was
the alpha on the show
yeah she's like overstayed her welcome i
i don't think she should have been a
part of this um reboot but
julia i think is one of the most
interesting women we've ever had on
housewives first of all when she said
her wife was martina i was shook like
obviously i've heard of who that was
like that's an actual famous person it
was just i wasn't expecting her to say
that i'm like oh my god and i also
wasn't expecting her to say she had a
wife like she's just so dynamic and so
you know
interesting she just is so different
than any of the women i think we're used
to seeing come on the show i think and
she lives on a farm like i think her
life with martina is so cool and
different and i think she's such a cool
girl like i could see myself wanting to
be friends with her she seems really fun
um and her being hungover and saying um
she's sick she's not hungover it's the
most ben software thing on the planet
like waking up after drinking like an
animal being like oh man i have food
poisoning no you had too much alcohol
like i hate when people do that
literally i'm glad the girls called her
out on it also calling 911 for a
hangover is insane like the way that
they were all being morons about her
hangover was infuriating infuriating um
but back to julia really quickly
when she shared that story about um
her
son
who was basically killed by their nurse
i was i never heard a story so crazy in
my whole life that's like something you
see on svu like shaken baby syndrome it
was so
sad
and so shocking and i tried to do a
little bit of research and there's like
you know theories that she was like with
a russian oligarch and
they had the
thing arranged like it's just so
crazy and i just made me love her even
more
yeah no she has such an interesting
personality story it's and all the women
like really gravitate towards her which
is just so funny because like they're
all the women are like so similar and
like into the same things and it's like
at the end of the day like everyone just
wants to be like loved by julia but i
think in general as it pertains like the
drama of the show like people aren't
really here for her presence because she
doesn't really add much but i think she
when she's around like character she
lifts the spirits of the other women and
makes everything a good time but also
like the way that she like enables
adriana and their friendship and like
the friend engagement was just it's a
big thing for me it's so weird i agree
like
she's an almost perfect housewife except
like her obsession with adriana is so
bizarre and like adriana bringing two
dates to the art show like i don't know
what adriana i think she's doing but
it's not working someone has to tell her
it's not working and also like aside
from the fact that adriana's behavior is
cringy and everything she tries to do
like just comes off like
so not as how she intended like she put
on this art show for this huge tennis
like this is a huge opportunity i don't
know what kind of other art shows she
does but like this is major the art is
really sweet like martinez like giving
her this i love the art and to even
bring one date to that like where you
have to like you're there to sell art
and to like schmooze and and
not to bring two dates and like make it
all about you just like again she just
completely misses the mark every single
time yeah
um also i really want to talk about
alexia's family dynamic because i find
it really interesting i watched the og
show i remember when frankie got in the
accident it was so
sad and i'm so glad to see him doing so
well he's such a sweet kid and every
time he's on
my screen he's just like be saying cute
things and i know alexia loves him so
much but the thing with her other son
peter is actually really crazy and while
i think maybe todd's
was a little harsh
i kind of agreed with his sentiment like
and you were the one who just told me
that like what did todd say he's like
you're gonna end up in jail like you're
a loser and you're gonna end up in jail
and last night and you just told me he
was arrested for domestic violence
against his girlfriend
he's a troubled kid he's a bad kid and
todd was like trying to warn and i think
alexia is a very sweet woman
but he wasn't wrong in saying that she
enables his behavior i mean even the
mere fact that he gave his younger
brother pot is
so insane
yeah and and he had that episode and he
doesn't even seem apologetic he's just
mad that todd yelled at him like he's
like a spoiled kid and he's like 25.
yeah no i totally agree i think people
were like yeah sure todd's message is on
point but the delivery was awful i don't
even think the delivery was awful
because i don't think they would have
heard him if he didn't speak in such
harsh plain terms i think like all three
of them really are used to being like so
coddled but also sometimes like it does
take an outsider to look at your
situation and be like you're not
handling it like and i'm sure alexia has
every well-meaning and i can't even
imagine what she's been through and so
it's no fault of her of hers but humans
are only equipped to handle so much and
like
i think that he's actually the perfect
partner for her because he's not afraid
like i think a lot of people would be
afraid like i don't want to step into
this i don't want to you know get i
don't want guys to represent me yeah i
don't want like alexa they're supposed
to get married like this could ruin
things for them but like he's really
more interested in actually seeing them
do
doing better
that he's like willing to sacrifice how
they see him for a second to let them
know what they need to know i thought it
was one of the most compelling scenes in
housewives like of a personal scene that
i've ever seen and i was so glad that
eventually they were able to hear what
he was saying and not just be mad at the
fact that and the way that he was saying
it yeah yeah i didn't like when he said
frankie's not my son
like yes he's not your son but like
you're marrying like that's just not the
sentiment you want to move forward with
yeah that made me cringe
and it made me cringe a lot of the
conversation was being had in front of
frankie um you were the one who told me
like you read this conversation was
actually two hours long and frankie
wasn't there for most of it but i think
the fact that he was there for even some
of it like was uncomfortable i it seems
like he was there towards the end when
there was like reconciliation happening
i don't think he heard the worst of it
even though they made it seem like he
did
okay
um but i just love alexia and i think
like the way she talks about the hermann
stuff i mean and marisol said it too
like i don't know if i would be as
graceful and and lovely um like the way
she just like really loved herman and
like isn't even she probably was at one
point but is now isn't even mad at the
fact that he cheated and had this whole
secret life she just like wants to know
like he was happy in
in that part of his life and i just i
don't know i just i think she's like a
really unique person i really like her i
think she's sometimes she comes off
badly with the other women because she's
just like she has so much going on she
can't deal with this moronic nicole and
lisa behavior like i get it but then
it's like marisol's like you know alexia
has so much going on yes
and then she's like her wedding got
cancelled i'm like wait that's not so
much going on that's like you know surf
sure it's stressful that's not the [ __ ]
that's keeping alexia up at night
right right so i didn't did a bad job i
agree completely agree i was like stop
saying that it makes it sound stupid
yeah um other housewives who are present
uh nicole and lisa i loved lisa then i
still really like her now and i i don't
know why i thought her personality was
like different than how it actually is
and she's very like chill and relaxed
and like sure of herself yeah oh but
a little boring too but i feel like she
definitely turns up um and i would have
thought like she'd be more of
like a people pleaser even with the room
stuff but the fact that like these are
all like seriously glamorous established
women and most of them are sharing rooms
and it's fine and she's just like no i
and i do understand like needing
personal space especially on a group of
course
i say that every time we go on a group
trip i'm like i don't care where we stay
i just want my own space and then i wind
up in a room with uh four people
um and i'm surprised no other housewife
in general like puts their foot down
about that but usually the women do get
their own rooms and i also think like
lisa is just like not that friendly with
anyone to be sharing a room with them
except for except her friendship with
lars i think is really like fun and when
she like is asking ourselves she can
stay with her and she's like shut down
it's like [ __ ] this lisa is totally
justified in wanting her own room i do
think like i understand larsa's
frustration because first of all to find
a house in the hamptons that's nice and
that fits and that has a pool and it's
on the beach like it's them it is an
impossible task and the fact that they
found that house is a miracle so i
understand larson being like enough but
lisa has every right to want her own
room but like the way she just like
demanded it like a spoiled brat like
that's the problem no one's questioning
like you
the like the reasoning you're entitled
to want your own space i totally get
that so why don't you just bow out be
like honestly like love you so much
thank you for sending this out like i
just would feel more comfortable at a
hotel like i just don't think
she she just was like trying to start
[ __ ] like she was being a [ __ ]
i think it was she it was like a long
travel day and she was grumpy yes i'm
gonna choke
um and nicole i really don't like her i
liked her in the beginning um
i think she came out a little strong
with all of her like personal scenes
like i personally don't care i don't
know you um that's like just my rule
like i need to have you for at least two
seasons before i care about your family
like that's just me sorry
um
and i do think some of the [ __ ] marisol
said i i actually believe marisol 100
because nicole didn't even deny it she
just like watered it down so i do
believe that she said that [ __ ] and i
feel like she was like let's just
normalize like judging each other and
yeah i guess but
like i i'm a judgmental person but like
i think some of the [ __ ] she was saying
was like really mean
yeah i think that they're both
both right sort of like first of all i
agree that she probably said those
things but it was also probably like
before she even met larsa like when if
we were if you were in that situation
it's like okay we're gonna be on the
show with this cast of girls and here's
this person and that person like we
would talk privately like about i mean
it's different because we're sisters but
like you would like you just say your
snap judgment's based on like what you
expect people to be like but i also
believe her when she says yeah i had
these preconceived notions and i was
wrong and i think that that's like kind
of okay i i thought she handled it in a
in a in a new way for housewives as
opposed to being like i didn't see that
or like doubling down she was like no i
i said that not as maliciously as you're
saying that i said it but also i was
wrong and and i really like you and i
felt like that was
kind of okay i i it was an it's an
approach it's a different approach and i
do feel like marisol was really trying
to start stuff and it's also like what
you think about someone
before you meet them versus like three
months later like at what point is it
irrelevant like we're friends now i said
this before i ever knew who you were
sure that's a poor reflection on me that
i would be so judgmental but like that's
just not no longer the case you know so
it's like yeah okay that on day one like
either say it at the pool party like oh
nicole you uh you now you met lars so do
you still think she's a hooker and you
don't want to be associated with her but
don't wait until two people become like
actually friends to like bring up some
old [ __ ]
yeah but don't you think like i
understand having like
misconceptions about people preconceived
notions um but don't you think like to
go from you're a hooker i don't want to
be associated with you to the
extensiveness of the platform is kind of
a big jump
yes come on
yes but it could be all it could be like
that she met larsa really liked her
which i can understand
you know i'm a big larson stan and also
before i saw lars how much it happened
live last week and you if you just like
asked me my thoughts on larissa pippen
just like if you asked nicole her
thoughts on larsa pippen before they
started filming together like i would
have probably said like
um you know
thirsty whatever but then like even just
watching her on tv i was like oh no
she's not those things so
that is what like nicole was saying it
is kind of just human nature and sure
it's better to like not share
unsavory opinions about people but i'm
sure they all were just talking about
like who are the new girls in the group
what's everyone been up to
and marisol just like booked what nicole
said and threw under the bus
i just really don't like nicole like i
was like living for that her getting
called out i do like gertie i think
she's like one of the best dressed
housewives oh my gosh all the women are
amazingly dressed gertie is a breath of
fresh air i know a lot she gets on the
other girls nerves and it made me really
sad when adriana said nobody here likes
you and only martina stood up for her i
was like
oh you know that was sad someone else
should have been like i like you unless
they really don't but like
julia you're literally she threw this
party for you julia speak up she threw
this party for you alexia she's your
wedding planner and your friend like
where was everyone else that just made
me sad um but i love her energy i didn't
even realize that
yeah i was just thankful that martina
said something because like what
what a shitty feeling
like to be horrible and also just
another poor reflection on adriana for
even saying nobody here likes you like
what are you 12
literally i also think um her marriage
is really a really sweet story like that
they met in the 11th grade and i love
that he's a firefighter obsessed they're
so cute i'm so obsessed and i i really
like i like her so much i don't know how
other people feel and i i guess like
some of the women don't like her and
she's a lot but i think she brings a lot
to
the party
that conversation personally resonated
with me i think i'm more of a gertie
than an adriana like i definitely am not
everyone's cup of tea i'm like loud and
annoying and so i hate when people are
like can you calm down like that's just
who i am [ __ ] off like don't be my
friend don't tell me to calm down like
that's like saying don't be me
yeah
yeah
so all in all i think it's a great
franchise i think it's really well done
i think
a lot of people are like let's get it on
bravo like as if that's some sort of
upgrade but i like it the way it is like
i don't know if they've been releasing
episodes episodically yeah or weekly
and next i like having a bunch to watch
and you saw the preview for next week
for this week
adriana talking about kanye
yes
i mean one again adriana the [ __ ]
quote and i look forward to seeing larsa
put her swiftly in her place
yeah
like i cringe i can't stand cannot stand
arjana
can not stand i'm glad we can agree on
that like she is the villain
a hundred percent but nobody even cares
let's talk about oh
like she's the villain you can't be the
villain if nobody cares about you
uh i hate i literally can't stand her
also i just want to say like larson
marie jewelry is so pretty i looked at
the instagram last night which is
expensive i know but lars is always
wearing like such nice jewelry and like
i like it's like dainty but also like
it's like fine jewelry i just like
really like the vibe don't be surprised
if i show up in similar summery jewelry
no i agree it's very on trend i stand
harder than ever just want to say
um let's talk about the chaotic mess
that was salt lake city last night where
we wrapped up the trip in zion and lisa
barlow absolutely lost her mind um i did
enjoy like watching her be crazy just
because she's so
in my opinion up until this point has
just been like so refined to the point
where it's like almost calculated yep
um her saying she was richer than all
the women like question mark question
mark question mark even though that's
not saying a lot i think this group is
running on fumes financially
um
she was being so weird i don't under
like i can't even recap this show
because i don't understand who's mad at
who for what for real
i can't recap the show
there
whitney's performance that last night in
the red dress like running around the
house like saying like where's mary
cosby to save meredith and also like
when meredith said literally
when mary when she went to the kitchen
to like bring up with meredith again
like to just just keep banging her head
against the wall meredith [ __ ] puts
her in her place swiftly to the point
where like whitney just has to like walk
away with her tail between her legs and
then she comes upstairs and recounts
what happened as if like she you know
was the she won she was the victor i'm
like girl and it wasn't until mary said
you know it's really frustrating arguing
with someone who's so drunk did i
realize that she was that drunk because
a few nights before a few episodes
before no it was um that night that they
were in
aspen or vale and everyone was coming
for mary they were dressed as like um
oktoberfest
and mary left because she's like i'm not
arguing with drunk people they won't
even remember what they said the next
day and you could tell that everyone was
really drunk and that mary wasn't so i
was like okay that's fine i didn't even
realize that at this junction
whitney was so drunk again that's why
she was making zero [ __ ] sense and it
was infuriating
to watch for me one of the biggest
moments of the episode was when meredith
flipped the tables on whitney and was
like what if i told you i didn't believe
you that you haven't heard from your dad
in months which is something obviously
whitney shared and heather and whitney
being in the back of the car recapping
that being like that's a low blow it's
literally what you did it's actually
it's not even as bad as what you did
because
meredith's dad passed away like what you
and i guess a lot of people are like
meredith why don't you just tell them
when it was and i get that but to
justify these morons these drunk morons
with the response it's disrespectful i
understand i know it's frustrating
people are like well if it really just
happened just like tell everyone what it
was so we could like shut up about this
no the fact that people are even asking
is so outrageous and that's why meredith
won't justify it with an answer two
things one not only did whitney like
could they not even see themselves
whitney misremembered what meredith said
meredith said what if i said your dad
you haven't not spoken to your dad in
months
and then in the car whitney said that
whitney said to heather that meredith
said what if i said that your dad's not
an addict so she didn't even know what
they're fighting about because she don't
know because she was so wasted and two
um as far as meredith not just sharing
the date it's like
even having to explain when the date was
and take you guys through my calendar
and my uh
planner
justify schedule of events justifies
this conversation so not only am i not
going to do that
but you at what point do you trust me as
a friend to know that i would not make
up in a memorial i i mean yes it's and
if i were in her position it's probably
just easier to be like here are the
pictures on my phone you can see where i
was like you're [ __ ] morons but also
like kind of just by leaving it
open-ended it's like look at yourselves
and what the [ __ ] are you doing asking
me about this
literally like you don't deserve the
peace of mind of like oh i get to ask
about every single personal thing in
your life and you have to tell me when
and where it was as opposed to just
being like meredith had a family thing
and we're going to leave it at that and
why would we even question whether or
not it happened when she said it
happened
and so then i don't understand
meredith's motives in inviting whitney
and heather over like i do think
meredith is trying to find a way in
which this all gets pinned on lisa and
whitney and heather are more than happy
to throw lisa under the bus but it
wasn't just lisa it was whitney and
heather more so than it was lisa
yeah i agree then she like comes and she
apologizes
immediately i think meredith is even
though she's like above it and she
disengages and she has no time for it um
i think she enjoys being a housewife and
so like she comes home she collects
herself and she's like okay now i have
to get back in the game like i think she
gets really frustrated with
on these trips and at these dinners and
stuff but then when she has a moment to
reflect she's like okay how do i get
back into like mary cosby has no [ __ ]
interest in being a part of this and but
meredith i think after she has like some
time to come to herself she's like okay
[ __ ] now i gotta get back to work who do
i start with i just can't believe that
we have spent hours and hours talking
about meredith's dad's burial and we
have not spent more than five minutes
talking about the egregious allegations
against jensha the insurmountable proof
that the fbi has that she was taking
advantage of the elderly the disabled
the old the vulnerable taking advantage
of all these vulnerable groups
stealing money from them there is a an a
huge amount of evidence that the fbi has
she's on trial she has to move out of
her house to pay her legal bills and we
as a group have not spoken about it for
one [ __ ] minute jen shaw and that's
why jen cha's staying out of it she
doesn't want to put her ass she can't
believe no one's asking her questions
how's shaw's internal bleeding like
sharif's internal bleeding
mind-blowingly stupid how these women
have [ __ ] up and really like lost the
plot
and
it's
beyond me
beyond and what's so crazy is on beverly
hills like we gave the women so much
[ __ ] for not holding erica's feet to the
fire when every single time they got
together it was brought up even if they
didn't you know say exactly what we
wanted to say or accuse erica of this
and that and mind you the crimes were
committed by erica's husband and even
still the viewers were like it's not
enough like even sutton who was doing
the most like still we were like she
could have done more she didn't really
say that much
they couldn't they could they couldn't
get together at all without it coming
back to erica and what she's going
through
meanwhile questions on there hasn't been
one conversation
between all of them about it and the one
time that there even was which was at
jenny's um
party in the garden it all turned into
like
fighting over who's
no and they're not the fact that they're
not being good enough friends to jen
like that was meredith's take is like
you need friends right now and your
friends aren't being good enough friends
and then they all have to prove how
they're such good friends to jen it is
so [ __ ] twisted and and
the main difference between erica and
jen is that these are gems crimes versus
these are tom's crimes alleged
right
it is insane to watch this season like
period even without the gen stuff going
on just like watching them all point
fingers at each other for like god knows
what honestly idiotic
knowing that there's this huge thing
that no one is going to talk about
and maybe it wouldn't feel like the
season is so bad or these women were
being so dumb if it weren't for jen's
like if this was just a regular season
without jen's crimes it would be like a
pretty good season everyone's being
crazy and yelling at each other pointing
fingers but the fact that there's this
enormous elephant in the room and i
don't think we've spoken about it since
she got arrested at beauty lab i mean we
had a historic moment nypd homeland
security showed up in utah on camera it
made such waves remember when it
happened we couldn't believe it
and now we were waiting wait a minute it
might as well have not happened after
the fifth episode where she got arrested
like goodbye i never heard from it again
when they said next week on the season
finale i can't even tell you this i
cheered leaf oh my gosh i said
and eve after watching
real houses of miami all weekend it's
like take for example the conversation
that was had at the table in montauk
between marisol nicole
and all the women and how they're
fighting over you said this and i said
that and like i'm able to follow that i
thought maybe my brain was just
scrambled that i can't follow housewives
arguments anymore so to watch out and be
like oh yes no i understand what's going
on and then to watch salt lake city and
be like what the hell is going on like
even when i i'm i'm not on my phone like
i'm hunkered down i'm paying attention
like i'm sober and i can't understand it
make it make sense and and usually it's
not you it's them usually i would say
like okay there's something we're not
getting you know maybe at the reunion
we'll get more context it's not even
that it said these women are like just
so
flimsy and they're also just they're
just like not serious women sorry no
it's they're they're horrible they're
horrible
so i'm very much looking and if andy
doesn't get some [ __ ] answers out of
jen shaw in the reunion i might be done
with this franchise for real it's not
even good i can't believe what we
thought we were gonna get versus what we
got and the fact that people think that
this is a great season like i can't
understand the low level you expect from
housewives because i don't know i grew
up in the bethany frankel jill zaran age
i just expect more sorry agreed and i
might have felt like a little bit maybe
it's me before watching real housewives
of miami like if i hadn't had that
experience this weekend i would be like
you know what it's just not for me like
i've outgrown no no no it's not me
it's that it's the producers it's the
cast because it can be done still and it
can be great and there's no reason
there's they've dropped the ball
completely this season and it's not me
no it's not you
um the last thing i watch that i want to
talk about is euphoria last name was a
monumental episode there was a lot of
chatter online like reporters being like
this is the episode where zendaya wins
her emmy it definitely was there was
really nobody else in the episode
basically
they left us on a cliffhanger last week
like
she was like she was doing a lot of
drugs and then like she was like at a
church so it seemed like she overdosed
and it turns out she she didn't overdose
she's in her house and her mom finds out
that she's back on drugs and her mom
wants to take her she's going through
withdrawal her mom wants to take her to
the emergency room they get in the car
and obviously her mom doesn't take her
the emergency room she takes her back to
rehab and when roo zandaya realizes this
she hops out of the car and this leads
her on like a
like a 24-hour crazy ass journey where
she's like looking for drugs looking for
things to sell because she owes the drug
dealer money she's you know trying to go
to her friend's house trying to get help
from anywhere stealing from her friend's
mom's house and she goes to the house
where all of her friends are at and
steals the mom's earrings but the mom
called rue's mom and they staged another
intervention
where rue
blows up this huge secret that she's
known for a while she says cassie how
long have you been [ __ ] nate jacobs
nate jacobs is maddie's boyfriend so it
was like i swear to god when roo said
that like i screamed i was just not
expecting like the idiotic high school
drama to show up
in this real drama this real life [ __ ]
and the acting was just so good like
maddie freaked out cassie starts crying
and there all this commotion starts that
all the women are like shut up we're
staging an intervention like it's not
about you and your stupid boyfriend but
the kids are just acting like animals
that zendaya is able to escape
so she's running around getting chased
by the cops throwing up everywhere she's
having crazy withdrawals she goes to her
old drug dealer's house who's like her
friend she tries to steal drugs from he
has um his mom is like hospitalized in
his house and she is like he's like like
a hospital in this bedroom she goes in
and tries to steal like the mom's
vicodin and stuff he throws her out she
goes everywhere she can until
she just goes to the woman she owes
money to his house and this woman's like
very weird we don't know her motives but
she's basically like you need to give me
the ten thousand dollars or i'll sell
you to people like you couldn't even
imagine so roo gets there and she's like
going through crazy withdrawals and
she's like please give me pills give me
pills and the woman's like i only have
morphine and i the only way to do it is
intravenously i think that means with a
needle and was like oh i don't do
needles
so she gets so desperate she's like all
right just give it to me so the woman
gives her more morphine obviously rue
like gets
knocked the [ __ ] out
and wakes up and like
she's in this apartment and she's
completely locked in the drug dealer and
her husband are there there's like a man
sleeping on the couch there's guns
everywhere there's locks everywhere
so it's clear that this woman who said
like if you screw me over like i will
sell you to the worst people on the
planet it's clear that
rue owes her money she's not gonna get
it and she's gonna sell rue into some
sort of like trafficking ring um
and everyone's asleep and it is jackie
the most
pit worthy scene of her trying to break
out of this house there's padlocks on
all the doors she's trying to get the
keys she sees the keys they're jiggling
they're not working jiggle jiggle jiggle
the man sleeping on the couch she goes
to the bedroom the man in the other room
wakes up he gets up rue's opening the
window she has to jump from two stories
her leg has been like broken this whole
time because she keeps running her
ankles definitely like sprained or
something
she jumps and then she's in the parking
lot of this apartment complex and
there's this big gate closing and she
has to run
run
run she makes it out of the gate
she like
that
scene
i swear to god i've never had such a pit
in my whole life because it's like if
you get out
where do you even go but if you stay
you're gone forever you're sold into
some something
so she gets out and we're like go home
ru your mom is looking for you she's
trying to help you even though like when
the sh roo said the most horrible things
to her mom like you know you're a
terrible mother like you know because
she was going through withdrawals i
don't think she really meant it
so the final scene of the episode is
rue's mom at the kitchen table she hears
the door open she says rue is that you
black screen
so we don't know if it was real we don't
know if it was that scary man from the
apartment coming for roo's family
because roo owes him ten thousand
dollars it was [ __ ] crazy and it was
like not even like the good euphoria
stuff that we love like you know the
cool outfits the high school drama which
we live for jacob lordy wasn't even in
the episode and it was chilling chilling
i'm queasy
jackie it was horrible to watch
literally like such a pit but definitely
zendaya earned herself an emmy
nomination or two i do think also sydney
sweeney will get nominated this year
because she's just
she's just killing it
um
it was painful like literally painful to
watch because she's like throwing up the
whole time she looks horrible because
she's going through withdrawals her
ankle's broken she's like running around
town and she can't even run because her
ankle's broken it was just
it was horrible you just want to shake
her like go home your mom cares about
you she wants to help you
oh my god
horrible like the scene where she's like
literally in someone's house stealing
money and then the people come home
early from dinner and they find her
under the bed it was just like
roo couldn't win she could not win
i can't that's crazy
and so her mom basically found this
suitcase of drugs under her bed and
flushed them down the toilet but the
reason why that's a problem is because
it wasn't rue's stash it was she took it
from the drug dealer and then was gonna
give the drug dealer ten thousand
dollars so that's why she's freaking out
the mom thinks she's like feeding for
drugs and like she is but i don't know
why she didn't just tell her mom mom
literally i have to pay this woman ten
thousand dollars and you just flush all
that down the toilet we need to go find
ten thousand dollars like because her
mom just thought she was being like
crazy roo feeding for drugs and she was
but she was also really feeding for the
money
got it but it's still drug money
yeah it doesn't matter though because
her life is at stake now with this crazy
ass drug dealer woman
oh
damn crazy show crazy show
well thank you for recapping it because
i've been seeing so much stuff like the
craziest episode ever and i you know you
wonder like what is the craziest episode
ever and that really does sound like it
it was the craziest episode ever
damn well this is the craziest episode
ever because we i can't shout out to an
hour and a half
oh my god 90 minutes we gotta go we
gotta go your girl's gotta pee
the chose instagram is still being
worked on i believe it will come back
just
just don't lose hope like okay it's just
taking a long time and we will tell you
all about it when it's over yeah thank
you guys so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so that's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i have radio cast box all
the places so wherever you listen to
podcast find us morning chosen leave a
five-star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
guys have an amazing monday and we'll
see you tomorrow for tuesday's show we
love tuesday we'll see you then goodbye